thanks very much to Elias and the other
organizers for the invitation it's great
to be back in Berkeley and at the time
is Institute so I'm going to be talking
about some project that I've been
thinking about for a while it's taken a
while to write not as difficult that's
because I have a lot of other things
that are on my mind so for many years
now I've been working on problems
related to high dimensional linear
regression and this slide is just for
some of the notation so you will want to
estimate the unknown parameter vector
beta star from iid observations X I Y I
where X I and beta star P dimensional
and Y is a scalar and what we have is a
situation where the number of dimensions
is larger than the number of
observations and therefore we'll assume
that there's some underlying structure
in this case Varsity of the unknown of
regression vectors so I'll very quickly
to the idea of how we can encourage
robustness so what we use is just
classical ideas from robust statistics
and the idea is that instead of trying
to minimize sum of squared errors if we
want to deal with some kind of heavy
tailed Nisour contamination in our inner
observation pairs then we might instead
want to minimize some other loss
function applied to the data so in this
setting L corresponds to the loss
function and this is just sort of a
textbook picture of the difference
between using ordinary least squares for
regression in a two dimensional setting
versus some other loss function so on
the left side you'll see different types
of loss functions including the usual
quadratic loss in contrast to things
like a Hoover loss which is here in red
so that's quadratic and then becomes
linear and then other types of non
convex losses and if you look at the
behavior just on these data points in
this picture you can see that the least
squares fit will sort of be halfway in
between perhaps the the true
the true curve and the outliers whereas
some losses such as Hoover and this
non-convex to key loss will tend to do
better okay so in classical robust
statistics there was a lot of focus on
sort of mini max optimality or or
optimality from the point of view of
asymptotic variance in the setting where
n is going to infinity and P is fix but
of course in high dimensions what might
happen is you need to change what sort
of objective function you're optimizing
and add some some other penalty to the
term and also analyze some slightly
different quantities so what we study
here is a penalized version of robust
regression functions so this is robust
because we're thinking about loss
functions that are not just the squared
error loss however we are assuming that
Y I and X I are still related via linear
model and I should point out that in
this linear model that I mentioned
before we're assuming still that all of
our epsilon czar iid from some
distributions so this not does not also
that the theory does not carry over also
to the case of adversarial contamination
although I really wish it did
[Music]
interesting
generalization that we're just looking
at estimation error so we want to know
how quickly the output converges to be a
star
all right so so we're going to assume
that the yeah that the errors so that
the robustness aspect to the the part
that that doesn't come from a standard
Gaussian linear model is that the
Epsilon's might come from some kind of
heavy tail distribution or if you want
they might come from a mixture
distribution where a 1 minus epsilon
fraction is sort of the clean nice data
and then the other epsilon fraction is
from some other distribution right so
what we want to do is in high dimensions
we want to analyze this particular
objective function so the questions that
we might ask are well first of all if we
actually want to look at a non-convex
loss function so these types of non
convex loss functions in the literature
are called
read ascending m estimators so the idea
is that if you plot the derivative of
this blue curve then the derivative will
descend down to zero and this
corresponds to this notion of a finite
rejection point so if you have points
that are beyond some radius away from
from the the true curve then the the
impact that they have on your estimating
equations is zero so if we actually
wanted to to optimize one of these M
estimation problems where the loss
functions are convex then even in low
dimensions we would have a problem a
problem in the sense that we need to
start to worry about well are there
local optima what do they look like and
do they also behave well and of course
when we add an l1 penalty that's not
going to make things any more non convex
so the same questions arise so what can
we do with the fact that there might be
multiple local optima and maybe another
question is just well I gave some
reasons for why one might use a non
convex loss function or something like a
Hoover loss in the classical setting but
in the high dimensional setting you
might be looking at slightly different
quantities and slightly different
notions of how one loss is better than
and this talk I'm going to try to
address these both of these questions so
then another important part of this talk
is this idea of scale calibration so
what does that mean and why is it
important well so if you if you go back
to just the idea of of why Hoover said
that the Hoover Lost was sort of the
best type of loss to look at and in
classical robust statistics there will
be this notion of looking at minimax
variants and minimax bias and the the
sort of derivation that one can write
down is that the Hoover loss is
minimized optimal when you look at the
asymptotic distribution of of the
estimator when you look at contaminated
data all right so if you are simply
looking at data from a normal
distribution then what minimizes the
asymptotic variance that corresponds to
maximum likelihood estimation and so
then you should look at some kind of a
quadratic loss if you're doing
allocation estimation why do you get a
Hoover loss which is quadratic and then
linear that's because you don't just
want to look at the best estimator when
you are looking at data coming from a
specific normal distribution you want to
look at a contaminated normal
distribution what does contamination
mean well we heard a bit yesterday about
Hoover's epsilon contamination model and
that's exactly what what this this talks
about this is like a CDF that is within
an epsilon neighborhood of the standard
normal CDF right so what you can do is
you can actually write down what what
this maximum sort of this worst-case
asymptotic variance would look like for
the Hoover estimator and compared with
all other M estimators you could
possibly write down and what happens is
that the the the best estimator the best
shape of an M estimator in fact is the
Hoover loss all right but there are a
couple things that you need to be a bit
careful about so obviously this is going
to depend on epsilon right because we're
looking at some min and Max some
worst-case neighborhood around a normal
distribution if epsilon changes then you
can imagine that the shape of your Hoopa
loss is going to have to change another
problem though is that actually the
derivation is also for a setting where
your look
a contaminated standard normal
distribution and if you actually write
down carefully what the shape of your
Hoover law should look like if you're
looking at not a standard normal then
there's also some hidden dependence on
signal okay so it's sort of this nice
clean theory which motivates the Hoover
laws and which is great because you know
we've studied Hoover loss in lots of
other areas since then and it's been
great for various reasons there are
still some sort of hidden questions that
you know one needs to deal with and yeah
so this is also what I'm seeing here
that yeah well you have a maximum
likelihood estimator and you need to be
a bit more careful depending on exactly
what what distribution you're looking at
okay so that was so this this previous
slide this is if you're just looking at
at a location family so it's like you
just want to use a more robust estimate
than the mean then.who bridge theory is
for one dimensional estimator and says
that you should look at a Hoover loss in
interesting regression shattering
setting it gets a little bit it gets
even more complicated okay so the
problem is then when you're looking at a
regression setting we're trying to apply
this loss function to the residuals and
the standard ordinary least squares
regression says that you apply the the
loss function you apply the squared loss
just to the residuals and then it turns
out that the scale parameter doesn't
matter so you can think about doing
maximum likelihood or your a regression
parameter estimator when you have a
linear model and when your data are
coming from a standard normal
distribution that's not standard normal
for a normal distribution with zero mean
in any variance you'll still end up with
the same maximum likelihood expression
where there's no dependence on Sigma
because Sigma will just come out and
Sigma squared however imagine a case
when you are not looking at a Gaussian
model so you could think about a
contaminated model but that just sort of
complicates things so for now just think
about some sort of other model where I
don't know maybe it's a t-distribution
well maybe it's a T distribution with a
couple more degrees of freedom so that
we have second moments okay so you
basically have some other distribution
than a some shape that's other that's
not the Gaussian the Gaussian model and
you can imagine writing down what the
maximum likelihood estimator will be
okay so the maximum likelihood estimator
will correspond
to another loss function which is not
the quadratic loss and I will have a
dependence on Sigma that you can't just
factor out okay so now we have a slight
problem because well if we if we ought
to figure out the beta that minimizes
this objective function then that's only
half the story so there are different
proposals that people have have given
over the last couple decades and one
that's kind of popular is that is what's
called the MM estimator so it's sort of
saying well if someone actually told you
what good scale parameter was or what
the actual scale parameter was then it
would be simple problems okay so even if
I were using a loss that wasn't just the
quadratic loss and was something that
corresponding to some weirder MLE I
could just plug in some estimate of
Sigma of Sigma star and and then I would
be back in the M estimation problem
again so it's not like all the problems
are gone I mean if I have a non-convex
loss I still need to optimize this thing
if I want to move to high dimensions I
still probably need to put a penalty on
it and analyze it okay but this slide is
just to say that in in linear regression
the unknown scale case is still kind of
complicated okay so as I said there have
been various various proposals in the
robust regression literature and they
all have you know some benefits and some
shortcomings so I think the these
authors here have thrown like that B's
that these estimators might have good
break down properties but then in terms
of optimization and where the local
optima lie it's the I think the theory
is still very much incomplete so I'm not
saying that we have solved these
problems I'm just saying that that my
proposal that I'll show you for getting
around the scale problem sort of
addresses the issues that are not
exactly addressed in these proposals and
just maybe to say a little bit more
about what other people have proposed so
it all comes down to having some good
estimate at the scale at least this mmm
estimator it's called an mm estimator
because some of the proposals say well
if I want to estimate the scale let me
use an M estimator of scale to get that
Sigma and of course one kind of can
imagine that you don't have to actually
get Sigma star exactly if you get some
good approximation of it then your beta
hat should also be approximately good
but then the question again is is how do
I get a good estimate of Sigma because
remember Sigma is not
the scale of your exes it's not the
scale of your why the scale of your
Epsilon
these are your residuals and if you
don't have a good estimate of the
regression parameter then how are you
going to get a good estimate of the
range of residuals so so some of the
proposals that seem to work well in
practice are to look at something like
least median of squares so least median
of squares says maybe you can look at at
the beta that optimizes this
optimization problem so this is a little
bit hard to parse but this is a
minimization only over beta and what
does it minimize it minimizes the the
median of the residuals okay so that's
what this this R means and then the fact
that I'm truncating at it and minus and
Delta means that I only want maybe the
bottom 90% so that things that are more
robust similar type of flavor is what's
called these trim squares regression so
these trim squares regression has also
been been suggested as a way to just go
ahead and solve the problem already
without estimating Sigma and the idea is
that instead of summing up the squared
residuals you sum up maybe the squares
of the bottom 90% of the residuals and
you call that fit beta so the MM part of
it says well let's just use that to
estimate beta because we don't think
that that will be the best estimate of
beta star that we can get altogether
let's use that as our estimate of beta
hat and then based on that let's maybe
take a median of the residuals that we
get and let's plug that in so these you
know these are well studied proposals
and as I said they seem to work well but
the theory in particular like will this
always find you a good local optimum if
there are multiple local optima is is
quite kind of unknown um yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's true yeah so
minimizing this is going to be a
non-convex problem right right right
right right so not only the computation
they difficult but also all the types of
analysis you might want to do to show
sadistic consistency that dependent
convexity don't work so yeah very non
convex problem okay right so here I say
that we these things will work if we
have some reasonably good initial
estimate of beta or Sigma but it's still
okay and then as I was sort of doing
more background reading on on what
people have done so there there's some
more sort of classical older papers
where people were addressing the
question not in the regression setting
but again just looking at location
estimation for how do you actually
choose this Hoover parameter if you
don't actually know what your Sigma or
your epsilon is these sort of proposals
exist and they have some characteristics
in common oppa that I'm going to
describe but not exactly so essentially
what they do is they they say well let's
choose different Sigma's and let's do a
sort of a grid of values and how do we
compare the quality of the estimates
well for every Sigma I get a location
estimator and I can use some sort of
estimate of what the asymptotic variance
should be and I do that for everything
in my grid and if my goal is to minimize
the asymptotic variance then I compare
all those proposals when I take the
minimum but again not not exactly known
well the theory is it's somewhat
incomplete here so so what I am going to
talk about I guess I'm not going to give
you the scale calibration part yet but
let me tell you what one can do when you
actually know the scale so sort of the
short story is that the proposal that I
have is that we are also going to kind
of compute the estimator for a grid of
scales but the way that we compare the
estimators isn't going to be quite the
method that I've just outlined so given
that my my idea is to compare the
estimator for a grid of scales the
question is well for a particular scale
parameter if we went back to this
regression setting and we plugged in
the regression setting is is here just
imagine it's this for the penalty right
so if we actually plug in a particular
scale then how does this behave so this
is a paper that I had a couple years ago
and and in this paper was exactly this
question actually to be honest when I
was preparing this paper I didn't quite
realize how much it depended on scale
because the assumption goes okay well
there is this scale parameter that you
are cooking into your loss function
right and then if you put the right
assumptions and the right assumption had
something to do with second moments of
Epsilon essentially being bounded by a
constant multiple of the scale but as
you dig deeper into the classical robust
statistics literature you realize if
that isn't exactly quite satisfying okay
so the type of result that came from
this earlier paper was twofold so for a
while now I've been interested in sort
of the interplay between global and
local optima and in certain statistical
types of problems and the nice result is
that one can show that both local and
global Optima of a certain type of non
convex loss function in particular the
type of non convex loss function that
shows up in exactly these types of
robust regression proposals have the
property that both local and global
Optima are close to the true beta star
okay and I'm going to to talk a bit more
about exactly what these conditions mean
so let me let me flip back to an earlier
picture so what these conditions mean is
that I still need some sort of curvature
of the loss function so the sort of the
saving grace if you look at at this
picture and comparing the red curve and
the blue curve to for instance the green
curve is that the green curve is an
absolute value and that has no curvature
at the origin whereas if you look at a
Hoover in a two key loss function well
they get kind of weird if you go further
away from the origin so think about
further away from the true beta star but
close to the origin they're still kind
of nice and they're more or less
quadratic okay so so the conditions that
I impose essentially say that you have
some nice curvature of your loss
function close to the origin so this
theory applies to cases like a Hoover
and to key loss and this probably seemed
it's reasonable to those of you who work
in high dimensional statistics because
you know that you always need some kind
of restricted eigenvalue a type of
condition and it has to do with the
curvature of the last function okay so
basically that is what allows us to to
use this sort of analysis on the other
hand if you use some kind of a non
convex to key loss then you could
imagine that since it becomes totally
flat further out there might be other
local Optima that are sort of further
away and this is something that you can
see in simulations as well and so the
the idea is that it's not true that all
of your local optima are bunched around
the global Optima which actually does
happen in in other cases but but what we
can guarantee is that certain non a
certain local Optima are well behaved so
so starting a local Optima meaning the
ones that are sort of close to the two
beta star are actually also bunched
together okay so so when you read this
statement it's it's not just saying that
that local Optima that are already very
close are very close so you can think
about are as sort of a constant radius
region and I'm saying that within this
constant radius region that's sort of
governed by the curvature of your to key
or Hoover loss any local optimum in that
region is actually very very close to
the other stuff okay and right and so
then there's then the question is where
is this hidden requirement that that
your scale parameter is is bounded so
essentially your scale parameter well
here I didn't even have a sigma cooked
into my L but essentially it's saying
that your your curvature of your loss
has to somehow respect the variability
because you want to think about it as
you're throwing down these data points
and you have some kind of let's say a
Hoover loss in multi-dimensions right
and you want your you know on your
errors to be so far out that they're
only on the place where the Hoover
losses is linear so you want you sort of
want to calibrate your width of the
Hoover loss which here corresponds
directly to this radius of your loss
function with the scale of your Epsilon
okay
and then I guess the other the other
thing to note is that of course if we
care about local and global Optima and
actually finding the good ones we also
need to guarantee that we can actually
find them and the other component of
this work was to say that in fact there
is a way to probably find them and as
it's common in a lot of the non-convex
literature these days it's the the idea
is that if you have a proper
initialization a clever initialization
then you can run some sort of
first-order algorithm for instance that
will find you a good enough local
optimum and so how would we do this well
so the the recommendation is that we use
something like uber loss at first okay
so the idea is so here I've kind of
written it out and in all of its
complexity so originally I was
interested in putting all sorts of non
convexity on my problems so think about
like a two key loss and a SCAD penalty
or something like that so if that's what
you actually wanted to optimize then
what you should do instead is you should
use some kind of a Hoover loss with an
l1 penalty first optimize that because
it's nice and convex find a solution and
then that provably will get you within
this nice basin of Attraction and find
you a good local optima okay so before I
move on to the next slide so one other
comment is well so when I came up with
this method I was excited but then I
also realized well I was sort of
thinking well if if the initialisation
already gives me a good point then why
do I run the second step right but of
course if you're more well-versed in
statistics you'll realize that you know
it's not just about consistency right
it's also about efficiency about
variance and in the whole way that I was
motivating coober loss to begin with was
saying look at the variance of view
estimators and when you start talking
about variances then you start thinking
about things like maximum likelihood
estimators and we think about a maximum
likelihood estimator for a distribution
that's not Gaussian then you really
should be using some kind of loss
function that's not convex okay so and
you can see also if you if you simulate
this process and you just look at the
variance of the first step only then the
variance of that estimator is going to
be worse in general than the variance
where you just run the second step
okay um so before I get to the scale of
calibration part I also want to say a
couple more words about this so I think
the the main stuff that sort of
demystifies what how the lost function
can play off against bad heavy-tailed
errors is the following so if you want
to analyze a lasso than what you would
normally do is you write down the basic
inequality so you say that you you look
at the sole a so it's just squared error
loss and l1 penalty and you say that if
you evaluate this at beta hat and you
compare it with beta star then you can
rearrange the terms and end up with with
some function of beta hat minus beta
star and then provided lambda is a
suitably chosen then you get this sort
of inequality okay and then the question
now is so where exactly is the
assumption that the Epsilon's are well
behaved coming in because if for last so
there was no assumption on epsilon is
being Gaussian or anything then who
really cares about this right okay so as
you'll know if the way that we get these
sorts of fast rates of convergence for
the estimator that comes out of the
lasso is we want to say well according
to this theory my optimal choice of
lambda should be to choose lambda as the
Infinity norm of X transpose epsilon
over N and if my epsilon is our sub
Gaussian and if my X is our sub Gaussian
or maybe if I have a fixed design in my
axes or well behaved then with high
probability this thing is bounded like
square root log p over and then so then
everything is great because if I choose
lambda correctly then the bound is like
spirit locking screw at K log P over N
so the nice thing is that if we now
change the calculation a little bit and
instead of using a squared loss function
but we use a different loss function so
we go back to how we were going to begin
with the basic inequality and we write
down an arbitrary sum of L of something
and we rearrange this inequality you
should also get some sort of a bound and
what happens is we end up with the same
sort of result but instead of looking at
x times the vector epsilon over N in the
infinity norm of that the loss function
the derivative the loss function is now
wrapped around the vector Epsilon so
it's L prime of epsilon 1 up to L prime
of Epsilon it
and so the nice thing is that now when
we try to to talk about the optimal
choice of lambda it no longer depends on
what the tails of epsilon are because
now we have this loss function the loss
function is counteracting whatever
epsilon is doing so if your loss
function is something like a Hoover loss
then your L prime is going to be bounded
right l prime is like linear constant
linear constant so no matter what your
epsilon tails are it's going to chop
them off and therefore L prime of
epsilon is going to be so calcium and
therefore we can plug in a square root K
log that's where a lot of people around
here all right so of course and so
technical challenges are of course I
only show it part of the equation so I
mean one thing I did was I only took
showed you a small sketch of a proof for
global Optima another thing is that as
you know a lot of the hard work in
showing these high dimensional results
comes in analyzing things like a
restricted eigenvalue condition so it's
not quite as simple as saying well write
down the basic inequality and then get
this inequality there's something else
in between where you need to look at the
curvature of your loss function and of
course now this is where we need to be a
little bit more careful so in in the
things like to key loss right we need to
worry about actually having this
curvature and actually having it so
that's where the epsilon can't be too
spread out because we need the curvature
to play well with with the variance of
the Epsilon's
yeah so so technically speaking in terms
of technical conditions this is
addressed by the local curvature of the
robust loss around the origin okay so I
think let me let me skip the details of
this and I'll just say that well so so
the very the very technical nuts and
bolts of this were that instead of
looking at a restricted eigenvalue
condition me to look at what has now
been known in the literature as
restricted strong convexity but then we
had to limit this to some constant
radius region because that's what's
satisfied by these sorts of two key
losses that are convex only in a small
radius let me skip do that oh great so
so now for the scale calibration um okay
so for the scale calibration part the
idea was it's actually very simple so I
thought about all sorts of other ways to
get around this problem scale estimation
that had to do with joint estimation of
beta and Sigma which you can do in in
certain cases but not in quite the
setting that I mean quite the generality
I wanted and so the idea was to use
lipski's method okay so so the slide is
kind of busy but as I said the idea is
is calculate the estimator on a grid of
values okay so here I'm just sort of
being a little bit more concrete on what
exactly my estimator means and all I've
done is I've changed my estimator a tiny
bit but this shouldn't bother you too
much so I just added weights W and W
other than that it's exactly the same as
before
it's just I want to do my robust
regression and I want to put a Sigma on
the bottom to to rescale everything
appropriately and then I have my l1
penalty okay
and the reason for the weights is simply
that I I want to be very broad in my
analysis I want to be able to say that
even if I have heavy tails in the X's
that's not a problem so some of these
proposals by Hoover for instance for
joint estimation of theta and Sigma so
kübra had a slightly different proposal
for a loss function that turned out to
be jointly convex in beta and Sigma but
the problem is that that's not going to
work in the case where your your exes
also have contamination so so in order
to deal with the case where the exes
might also contamination you add some
weights technically speaking when you
start to take derivatives of things and
make them concentrate you don't only
have to deal with X but you can deal
with W times X and this is a good thing
because what does your W look like well
it's often well in its proposed it was
proposed in the literature before also
as this sort of an estimator that
basically says if you get too far away
then just pull it in okay so it's saying
I'm still looking at an MST area but
some kind of a weighted M estimator
where I want to also pull in my X's of
course this might also bother you
because now we're getting further and
further away from maximum likelihood
estimation right because like if if I
actually had heavy tailed X's and heavy
tailed Sigma's I probably don't want to
just arbitrarily pull things in and
that's also why it becomes then
important even more important than
before perhaps to talk about the
efficiency right so even if we get a
good initial estimate how do we get
behavior that's about as good as if we
actually solving the maximum liquid
problem alright um so back to lipski's
method so lipski's method is a method
for sort of adaptively
yeah question what does B be is going to
be constant so little B and Big B are
going to be constants and the rates will
of course depend on these B's yeah but
you can also think about these are just
a way to get an initial point so it's
fine if it's kind of right maybe is a
matrix yeah because X is a vector
sorry so big B is going to be a P by P
matrix little B is going to be a scalar
you can set it to be whatever you want
yeah it could be a diagonal matrix if
you want yeah I guess if you wanted to
make things truly optimal if your X is
sort of an isotropic shape you would
probably want to scale things
appropriately but here again we're not
worried about efficiency for the time
being okay so so what is that skiis
method well let's say method as I said
it has kind of gotten more attention
recently because I guess it's it's
important to be able to calibrate things
these days and there are many things to
calibrate and in my concluding slide
I'll mention other things that I would
really like to calibrate but aren't
quite as easily done okay so the idea is
that we want to compute the estimator on
a grid of values but we're not going to
well the way that we're comparing these
estimators is going to be pairwise
comparisons and at the end of the day
we're going to categorize the points
into either a good or a bad set and then
we're going to look at the good set and
take a minimum over that good set okay
so what does this look like well so
first I should also mention that how you
can apply lipski's method is that you
you apply the sort of method when there
is a range of values for a particular
parameter you're trying to figure out
the best value of that parameter and
what you know is that if the parameter
is bigger than some magical value that
you don't know the estimator will behave
well however if you get further and
further away from the magical estimator
the quality of your estimate will get
worse and worse in a way that you
understand and that's exactly what what
is happening here because here according
to the
that I told you um if we actually choose
the scale parameter well I guess I
didn't exactly make it explicit but you
can imagine you know if the optimal
thing to do is choose your scale
parameter to be examiner of your Hoover
loss to be exactly the right scale
parameter if you overshoot by it a
little bit you'll lose in in in the
rates of estimation error right so if
you if you go all the way out if your
scale parameter goes to infinity you're
just doing least squares least squares
is consistent it's just that the rate of
convergence of beta hat to be the star
is suboptimal right so what we do know
is that for any any choice of the scale
parameter that's and that's big enough
we get a guarantee for the estimation
error it just gets worse and worse as we
get bigger and bigger and that's exactly
where we can use map skis method so
let's give a method says well let me
find some rough parameter balance and so
what I'm proposing in this is well okay
we want to know what is some good
estimate of epsilon I the variance of
that we have no idea what epsilon is but
we do know that if epsilon and the X's
are are independent then we can look at
the variance of Y and that should tell
us some kind of upper bound an epsilon I
and the good news is that you only need
a very rough a rough
range on signals on what Sigma star
could be because at the end you're going
to look at some kind of a doubling or
log scale whatever so you start with
Sigma min you'll get twice of that and
four times at that is better at that
okay so then the procedure says well for
every candidate Sigma J so let's imagine
I'm trying to decide whether Sigma J is
in the good center of the bad set let me
evaluate the estimator for everything to
the right of it and let me compare those
two estimators so what does that do well
first of all it says that everything
that's in blue will with high
probability by a union bound be in the
good set okay because I know that so by
it being the good set I mean that the
difference between the two estimators is
going to be twice of this radius right
so I don't know what beta star is and I
knew it made a star was I could just
compare anything as beta star but then I
would know what beta stars there's
nothing to do so all I can do is I can
compare pairwise estimators and I know
that if both of them are in the goods
are in the blue region anyway then they
should pass my test because the
difference between beta hat and that one
of them and the other one should be less
than or equal to twice of this radius
right okay but you know ellipses method
is designed for a setting when I
actually have no idea how the estimators
will
in the white region so they might be
good they might be bad and the nice
thing is that lap skis well at the end
of the day what I'm going to do is I'm
going to declare everything that passed
the test good and then I'm going to
choose the minimum as my choice of
sigma-star and if it so happened that I
chose something that was that was less
than Sigma star then the nice thing is
that beta hat evaluated at this point is
guaranteed to be very close to beta star
all right so it's not necessarily
guaranteeing that the solution I get by
doing the screening and choosing the Arg
min is actually going to be close to
Sigma star but it is telling me that the
beta hat evaluated at that Sigma is
close to the beta hat at Sigma star why
is that because at some point I was
doing pairwise comparisons to the right
and if Sigma J passed my test that means
I must have compared it with something
awfully close to Sigma star and
therefore beta hat Sigma star is going
to be close to beta hat Sigma J okay so
that's the idea so just to repeat the
method is simply compute on a grid of
values but then you have this extra
screening method that tells you what is
in my good set what's in my bad said I'm
going to take the min over all of these
okay so at the end of the day you end up
with a result and for those of you who
have used lab skied method this is not
surprising and the hard work in in
showing this is not to show that
lipski's method works but to show the
required inequality that will then allow
you to apply lipski's method okay and so
then of course then then there a couple
of comments so I mean I think there are
various constants that are hiding things
so what am i hiding what am I not hiding
well so what I what I am hiding is that
of course the estimation error bounds
will depend on some kind of restricted
eigenvalue condition and why is this a
problem potentially well I mean these
sort of constants are all going to are
all going to show up in in the
comparisons that I'm doing in lipski's
method so I've been telling you that
this constant is hiding something about
the restricted eigenvalue constant which
is a property that design matrix then I
also need to worry about that when I'm
actually using lipski's method with this
big seat my my my justification for that
at least for the time being is that well
I mean I think assuming that you know
something
the distribution of the design of the
covariance is still somewhat weaker than
knowing something about the distribution
of the Epsilon's all right because in
theory if you had a lot of a lot more
data you don't even need the pairs of X
iyi pairs but if you have more
observations of X I maybe you could
estimate something about the curvature
or restricted eigenvalue parameters I'm
not saying this is realistic but at
least it's more realistic than being
able to say someone will tell them if
someone has told me something with the
distribution of the epsilon okay so this
does not require any knowledge of the
scale parameter of the epsilon another
nice thing is that the way that we've
set things up so there's been a lot of
work on tuning free lasso type
regression usually lambda depends on the
scale of the epsilon but we've set
things up in such a way that it doesn't
depend on that so so technically you
don't actually have to have to chew in
lambda here okay
so now maybe let me just say a couple
more words on efficiency so there's
something that I've sort of started
around and it's also an area where I
think there is still much work to be
done I think nobody has really had the
last word on efficiency and high
dimensional regression settings so but
at least what what I've done here to
improve the efficiency of my estimate is
to follow this literature also from
classical robust statistics and how to
improve the efficiency of M estimation
and so Peter Bickle has this very nice
paper that proposes or I should say well
there were others who also proposed this
but he analyzes rigorously the behavior
of these so-called one-step M estimators
and this was exactly for the setting
when you might want to minimize some
other M estimator from the point of view
of maximum likelihood estimation but all
you might do to begin with is to
minimize some sort of convex function
and start with the initial point and the
the bottom line here is that in fact if
you just do one step of what turns out
to be Newton's Newton's method for
minimizing the loss function that you
really care about
then asymptotically the behavior of the
single step estimate is the same as if
you were actually to minimize the real
maximum likelihood non convex problem
that you wanted to and this is something
that has been studied that has drawn
attention recently in ordinarily square
high-dimensional lasso estimation
because people were interested in doing
inference and trying to construct
confidence intervals and so the nice
thing is that there's already some
mathematics in place for understanding
and analyzing what these amounts of
estimators might look like okay so so
that the basically what I'm what I
proposed in what I derived some math for
was to say that in fact if you do this
sort of one-step estimator then the
asymptotic variance that you end up with
is exactly what you would like to have
so maybe I should just modify like
explain this a little bit more so if you
study robust regression a robust M
estimation and you're looking at the
asymptotic variance of an estimator then
the sort of term that shows up is going
to be so size your derivative of your
loss function this type of term that
shows up as your asymptotic variance
it's exactly something like expectation
of size squared times your distribution
over expectation of psy prime squared
the nice thing is that if you now look
at the best possible side that minimizes
this factor then that corresponds to the
negative log likelihood which I think I
wrote done somewhere yeah so maybe I'll
go back so so it turns out that the best
possible side that you could use here to
minimize this term corresponds to the
neck to the derivative of the negative
log likelihood right because so here psy
is my derivative of my loss function so
that's basically saying that if I do
maximum likelihood estimation so I use a
negative log likelihood function then to
get the minimum asymptotic variance I
should be taking a derivative okay so
maybe I won't go into more detail here
but I should just say that where where
this was not exactly completely
satisfying is that I mean I think what
we would like to do a lot of the time in
in high dimensional statistics does not
just look at sort of the asymptotic
limit and what we would really like to
do is perhaps look at the the variance
of an estimator as a function of N and K
and P and understand exactly what is the
right the right loss function to be
using in that sense so well maybe let me
just wrap up with this slide in the
conclusion so as I said there are other
things that would be great to be able to
calibrate I have thought about them a
little bit
I don't really know exactly what to do
so what to do yet so one thing that I've
thought about on and off is just this
least trim squares objective function I
thought about it for a while because I
thought well if someone can actually
analyze what the optimum of this very
ugly objective function looks like say
that that solution is quite close to
beta star and then try to recover a
sigma from it and that would solve all
my scale parameter problems now I'm
approaching this from a slightly
different perspective which is that
somehow if you if you want to do at
least trim squares and you're looking at
maybe an epsilon contamination model or
something like that then you would
really like you're trimming parameter to
depend on on something that you don't
know ahead of time okay so the idea is
you have some kind of outlying this and
I'm not quite sure what way and maybe
you could imagine something like easing
laps keys method and choosing your
trimming parameter and the problem is
that well first of all we don't really
have a guarantee I think on how well
your estimator will behave but also the
way lipski's method is designed you want
your error guarantee to depend in some
way on the parameter you're choosing and
it's not quite so clear here and then
another question that I mentioned
earlier is just this idea of doing
one-dimensional location estimation
where you don't know Sigma you don't
know Epsilon now you have two things to
play with and as far as I know nobody
really knows what a proper variant of
lipski's method would be in multiple
dimensions and if one could solve that
then there would be lots and lots of
great things that one could do not just
in this field but also other problems as
well so yeah let me just wrap up with
that so thanks for your attention and
this is almost on the archive it will be
early next week
[Applause]
[Music]
so you focus throughout on estimation
error what happens if you do prediction
error and is there like an easy way to
fix something like cross-validation then
to pick your skin from it I haven't
thought about prediction error I haven't
seen classical robust statistics work on
prediction error but I could be wrong
they're asking one of the experts here
at Berkeley would be a good idea
no question so in your previous site you
said something about the small cuber
yeah just isn't that perimeter like the
SI perimeter or whatever wherever you
start to switch to the linear well yeah
yeah yeah so that's what I'm saying so
if we go if we step away from regression
and we start to think about the optimal
humor poober parameter for the point of
view of just yielding an msdemeaner for
location estimation then the nice theory
in the classical statistics books will
tell you that exactly what that optimal
parameter should be as a function of
Epsilon
assuming that the scale is one assuming
that you're contaminating a standard
normal and if you try to solve the
problem instead where you have you don't
know epsilon and eat well I mean for a
different epsilon and a different scale
then your goober Herold find on both of
those so then the question is yeah so
somehow you de call with some adaptive
way that would deal with both of them
he's said early on that you kind of wish
this would also be good for adversarial
contaminating are there any assumptions
we can make you know if the adversary
isn't arbitrary but you think this
analysis can extend no I mean currently
everything depends a lot on things being
iid I mean I've thought a bit about
trying to prove something about Hoover
lost in the case of of adversaries that
can choose the points I have some bound
but I'm not perfectly happy with it so I
mean my belief is that Hoover is
probably a good thing to do also an
adversarial contamination but I don't
know if anyone who can really prove that
right now it's a new alias the
investigators this is the petitioner is
a musician problem but if you solve your
good like we even know that the starter
at Huber contamination model is going to
give you a regression factor which is
never be close like to be the one in
adversarial case you've been a superbug
miserable yeah and that's I think you
should be fine yeah in third more tips
you only have arrows it's fine if you
only have Epsilon's that are control I
mean our X's and Y's are not touched
I mean her wiser but if the exes are
random this is what the exercise I leave
it to you all but if the answer mark
yeah
I have something just you sort of use
efficiency as a benchmarking in high
dimensions is that the right thing to
look at yeah I mean you can't achieve it
in some sense like only unless you look
at the single coefficients are small
yeah exactly yeah that's where this Jay
was hiding out yeah and so what what is
the night notion yeah this I don't know
I mean I I started studying alright I
derived these results on efficiency
which were based on what a lot of other
people had done right
simply because I wanted to understand
for myself can I justify the reason for
using two key laws instead of Hoover
laws so that at least sort of justifies
it right or like how can I deal with the
fact that I just tacked some arbitrary
weights on things and now my solution
might everything library yeah that I
also don't think anyone has an answer to
that
so so that was something that that was
from my earlier paper which I guess now
that there's this lipski's method thing
I don't know that it would be necessary
to do that second stuff but at least
that was also an attempt at dealing with
the efficiency and there I what my
crutch there was varsity so it's like if
we have sparsity in the beta
mint-condition then everything is just
in kata mentions anyway so then you can
look at the variants and K dimensions
[Applause]